dr. Harry Edwards joins me here on the
rich eyes and showed you agree with that
assessment
dr. absolutely absolutely he's
absolutely correct and I'm glad that he
has the courage to step up and say it
there's no question about that and I
think that we really need to take an
assessment of what we're supposed to be
about in the National Football League we
have a league where we have people
playing under contract who committed
murder we have people who are came back
in the league after being convicted of
dog fighting and dog killing people
who've been charged with rape
driving under the influence vehicular
manslaughter beating on women they
drafted a young man out of Oklahoma who
hit a woman so hard he could have killed
her over something she said give me a
break but all of that's okay and people
don't mind going out and cheering for
that but if somebody takes a knee and
says essentially we are better than this
in under circumstances where between 18
for 82 and 1968 when dr. King was killed
this country averaged 40 lynchings of
black men women and children a year from
1968 until 2014
we have averaged over a hundred and
forty of black men women and children
shot down in the streets and even in
their homes and cars by police officers
officers in this country not to speak of
over 5,000 murders fratricidal murders a
year in the african-american community
owing largely to the circumstances under
which these people are forced and
compelled to live so we need to you can
be honest when you can't be right and do
I support mr. Bennett absolutely because
it's the truth
when was the last time you spoke to
Colin Kaepernick dr. Abel's to cap maybe
three months ago basically I try not to
get too much he has a management team
which does an excellent job and I think
that too many people in his ear doesn't
do anybody a benefit not to speak of the
fact that he's his own he's his own man
he does his own thinking so I mean but
you also understand that there could be
and I'm just throwing this out there
that a football reason as to why he has
not been signed
at least at some people saying that in
terms of the amount of money he's asking
for and his demand about wanting to
start or anything so you're unfamiliar
with any of his dances on that front no
I'm very familiar with but what you're
arguing and when you put that out there
is that there are 64 starters and
backups who are on rosters who are
better than Catholic not to speak of 32
clipboard holders who are better than
Catholic and no one can find any logical
or rational football basis to bring him
into it into camp at least to compete I
don't buy that
that is not only irrational it's it's
the height of is the height of sophistry
the veracity of that kind of statement
is laughable so you can't you simply
can't argue that dr. Harry Edwards
professor emeritus of UC Berkeley
joining me here on the Rich Eisen show
so why do you think that there is no if
you want to put a fine point on a
courage of conviction by one NFL team
right now well I think that people are
looking to see how circumstances evolve
I think that they are concerned as
somebody said the reaction could run
anything from a letter from Donald Trump
to a you know some gaggle of fans who
have access to a crayon who can write
nasty letters and death threats and
everything and teams are reluctant to
deal with that along with the fact that
you also have to deal with cap issues
there are a lot of issues that roll into
it but at the end of the day what it
comes down to is that you have an
athlete out there who has taken his team
to a Super Bowl who has taken his team
to two conference championships who had
a extraordinary an extraordinary record
of success prior to an injury who is now
over that injury back up the playing
speed and as Pete Carroll said after
working them out at Seattle this guy is
a starter and nobody can find room for
him and camp even to come in and compete
for a job no I don't care
the explanation is that is one that
nobody can rationally explain our excuse
what would you say to somebody dr.
Edwards who's hearing you right now
maybe even for the first time sitting
there saying yes but he took a knee on
the American flag in front of God and
country yes he also put on socks
practiced in socks that had a police
officers had on top of a pig and that
that is something that they cannot get
past what do you say to somebody like
that dr. pepper they can get past uh
murder they can get past vehicular
manslaughter they can get past drug
abuse they can get past somebody hitting
a woman hard enough that it could have
possibly killed it they can get past
domestic violence they can get past all
of that they can get past even some
owners who have been accused of rape
they can get past all of that then don't
tell me anything about some Pig sites
which even Colin said that was a mistake
I talked to him about that he said hey
that was a mistake and and that is
something that does not move the
conversation forward but as far as him
taking a knee Hey look I've lectured at
every major institution in this country
for all practical purposes 1,300
lectures over the last 50 years I went
to West Point and lectured and I'm
standing there there playing the
national anthem with these young people
who know when they come out of there
they're not going to a major corporation
to the NFL or own to some Ivy League
school and get a PhD they're probably
going to go to Afghanistan they're going
to go to Iraq and they're standing there
and that they're playing the national
anthem and it brought tears to my eyes
they know when this country called they
didn't ask about the politics of the war
how we're going to pay for it or is
there an exit strategy who's the
president they step forward voluntarily
and said send me you have to honor that
but there's a backside to that and it's
in the very first line of our United
States Constitution it says We the
People in order to create in order to
form a more perfect union it doesn't say
we to people with the exception of
athletes it doesn't say we to people
when everybody is comfortable with
statement that we make and as common
looked around and saw these summary
executions saw the injustice saw the
incarceration rates saw the lack of
resources and so forth in this community
what he essentially said is that we're
better than this and when you won't
listen to that kind of a statement I
would have been gratified if the man who
went into that baseball softball game
practice yesterday and started shooting
people if he had waited until a game
started and they played the national
anthem and he went out and took a knee
and said I just want to remind you of
what you're really here in Washington DC
for I would have been gratified at that
instead of doing what he did this is
what cat was trying to do this is the
message that he's trying to send he's
saying that burden falls on we the
people not we the president so we the
court so we to Congress or we lemare the
governors the Constitution and the very
first line says we the people and that's
critical that's important well how does
this compare dr. Edwards to the 60s I
mean how do these times that seem to be
so troubled and the discourse so widely
disparate how how how does this compare
where where there's an athlete that that
is not employed right now compared to
for the lack of a better analogy
anything that was going on in the 60s
with athletes speaking up Ali wasn't
employed after he took a stand on the
Vietnam War Thomas Smith and John Carlos
were not employed after they took a
stand for justice and human rights Bill
Russell was called felton X after he
stated that we have some problems not
just in the South but in Boston you had
people across the board a Curt Flood was
unemployed after he said that we have to
have the dignity of and respect to at
least be able to have some say in where
we work as American citizens he was
unemployed so there's nothing new about
not being employed and we're just lucky
as a society that we have people who are
still willing to pay that price in order
to make a state but in order to do
something that you can't do in Russia
that you can't do in Saudi Arabia that
you can't do in God and Qatar that you
can't do in China but that you can't do
in Cuba he can step forward and say hey
here is where we Americans begin to deal
with these issues and here buddy it dr.
IRA Janice didn't you know just if you
don't mind no because it because this is
just brings up I guess to to round off
the conversation best we can
the ultimate conundrum with this because
what you just said is so right that that
he does have the ability to do this
Kaepernick in a society unlike those
other countries that you may get you
name but so many people can't get past
the fact that he took a knee on the most
symbolic aspect of that spirit in the
flag like of what symbolic of what
symbolic of standing there with your
hand over your heart and singing a song
while people are being shot down in the
street that's not what we Americans do
we deal with these issues this goes back
to slavery this goes back to the Civil
Rights move this goes back to the
women's rights movement this goes back
to the Voting Rights Movement this goes
back to all of those efforts to form
that more perfect society and it doesn't
happen by standing there singing a song
with your hand over your heart it
happens by people stepping forward and
saying we are better than this so just
do I guess end the conversation what
what do you think this means for
athletes moving forward do you think
you're going to continue I think that
just the Jackie Robinson step forward
and paid a heck of a price I'm convinced
after talking to him as well as watching
his career throughout from World War two
until he died that it's that what he did
shortened his life the same as Smith and
Carlos and Bill Russell and Jim Brown
and Muhammad Ali and Arthur Ashe and
Curt Flood and all of those great
athletes
Washington woody strode all those
athletes who pay the price
it was so hard on what he strode he said
when he came out of UCLA and integrated
the NFL in 1946 that if Heaven is
desegregated I don't want to go that's
how hard it was on him so at the end of
the day it's going to continue this cup
these coming years are going to involve
athletes dealing with issues that are
well this side of the social political
horizon they will be taking stands they
will be paying prices and there will be
people who will be very unhappy about it
but there is nothing more American than
a Jackie Robinson or Bill Russell or
Smith and Carlos or an Arthur Ashe or a
Colin Kaepernick even if it takes them
50 years or Muhammad Ali even if it
takes them 50 years to recognize it and
feel comfortable with dr. Edwards love
talking to you always thank you thank
you today sir otherwise you got it it's
dr. Harriet the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that please download our app there's
lots of fun things there other than just
more of the videos you just saw you can
call us from the app you can email us
from the app just download it trust me
you'll enjoy